ON HIM.
AGO, SPURS
McDERMOTT MAKING THE NICE PLAY.
Y
TO CHECK INTO T
HE'S ACTIVE.
AND THE BEST PART ELOQUENTLY
AS WELL THIS MORNING.
>> Mark: YES,HE ANTICIPATION,
BANE, THEFREE THROWS.OFF TOP OF
WILL
BEAUTIFUL. SLICING THROUGH THE
DEFENSEAS IN THIS ARENA LAST
SEASON, THIS IS A GAME WHEREDRU
AYO MY
>> Alvin: TALK ABOUT THAT WEAK
SIDE DEFENCE.
GOT TO BE ABLE A FOUL IS GOING
CHARGED TO THE RAPTORS.
OH, COUNT IT  FROM
WILLIAMS.
SUCH
>> Richard: LUKA DONCIC.
A LOT IS MADE OFAGAIN. DEFLECTS
HUSTLE RIGHT THERE.
TERRY HELD THEM UP.  CURRY TONI
>> Bob: KSEVEN REBOUNDS.
OUR >> PLAYING IT
OTHER WAY.
CLIPPERS DOWN BY ONE. I'M , HOL
COW.
TIMEOUT, ORLANDO.
THE GRIZZLIE
JAYLEN BROWN WITH THUNDER ONALL
THAT!